en este vídeo quiero hablar acerca del
mercado laboral del mercado laboral la
moral esto básicamente es el mercado del
trabajo así como se pueden ofertar y
vender manzanas se puede ofertar y
vender trabajo las personas se ofrecen
para trabajar y las compañías las
contratan las compañías necesitan
contratar personas para poder producir
pues lo que tengan que producir vamos a
empezar con una sutil diferencia y que
la voy a poner por acá y no se pensemos
en el mercado de computadoras
computadoras en el mercado de
computadoras quien hace la oferta oferta
y quien hace la demanda la demanda
pues aquí en el caso de las computadoras
la oferta la hacen las empresas
voy a poner aquí empresas las empresas
son las que ofrecen computadoras y la
demanda de computadoras la hace la gente
la gente por otro lado en el mercado
laboral laboral justo pasa al revés
verdad la oferta la oferta de trabajo
las en la gente la hace la gente y la
demanda de trabajo los que necesitan
trabajadores manda ahora son las
empresas empresas de esas muy bien esa
es una primera distinción antes cuando
vimos la estructura de ingresos de una
de una compañía podíamos ver cómo
justificar una curva de oferta verdad
pero ahora en el mercado laboral vamos a
ver cómo está la estructura de costos y
con eso vamos a poder justificar una
curva de demanda que también vamos a ver
como una curva de beneficio marginal
pero bueno ahorita pasamos a eso primero
es entender esta sutil distinción y
ahora vamos a pensar
que tenemos un lavado de autos va
entonces nuestra compañía va a ser un
lavado lavado de autos
y una cosa importante de este lavado de
autos es que va a ser competitivo
competitivo y va a ser competitivo en el
sentido de que no es un monopolio vaya
no es un monopolio no es un oligopolio
es decir este lavado de autos está
compitiendo con otros lavados de autos
de la ciudad y entre todos ellos pues
están intentando obtener la clientela y
ofrecer sus servicios y lo que sea pero
bueno aparte de ser un mercado
competitivo y es que hay un precio
estandarizado y un precio pero es un
precio promedio de lavados de auto en la
ciudad y digamos que es de 50 pesos van
que cada lavada de auto le voy a poner
50 pesos por lavada de auto entonces
cada lavada de auto cuestan 50 pesos
para esta es una parte de ser
competitivo pero la otra parte de ser
competitivo es que el beneficio marginal
por lavada de auto va a ser siempre de
50 entonces una lavada nos da 50 2
lavadas nos da 100 pesos 3 lavadas nos
da 150 siempre vamos aumentando de 50 en
50 y eso es por ser un mercado
competitivo si estuviéramos en un
monopolio sabemos que eso no pasa que el
beneficio marginal puede ir cambiando
según la cantidad de autos que la vamos
pero bueno entonces es constante va
siempre cada auto adicional que lavamos
nos da 50 pesos ok en esta situación lo
que quiero saber es cuántos trabajadores
cuántos lava autos me conviene contratar
y para eso supongamos que estuve
investigando y que obtuve la siguiente
información de promedios de la industria
por aquí tengo la cantidad de labor o
puedes pensar esta l como la cantidad de
lava autos que el contrato y aquí
tenemos el trabajo si vamos a ponerle el
producto del trabajo entonces si tenemos
digamos
cero lavadores entonces esto nos da una
cantidad de cero autos lavados luego si
tenemos un lavador podemos lavar cinco
autos si tenemos dos lavadores podemos
lavar le voy a poner nueve
3 son 12 autos que podemos lavar 4 son
14 autos y finalmente le voy a poner que
con 5 lavadores podemos lavar 15 autos
muy bien entonces esto de acá es
información de cuántos lavadores nos
pueden generar los cuántos autos lavados
por ahora digamos entonces podemos
pensar estas cosas por ahora déjame
ponerle por acá y estoy le voy a poner
el lavadores que tengo por ahora o sea
aquí es que tengo dos trabajadores por
ahora y así entonces son son lava autos
para poner lava autos por hora
y aquí el producto de trabajo es coches
que podemos lavar por horas entonces son
coches por hora
muy bien entonces hasta ahí tenemos esa
información déjame graficar la para que
tengamos una mejor indicación de cómo se
ven las cosas voy a poner por aquí el
eje vertical aquí el eje horizontal
entonces quiero marcar estos primeros de
acá aquí voy a poner elabora aquí lo voy
a poner lo mejor aquí voy a poner el
labor bueno es que aquí va labor y aquí
voy a poner el producto del trabajo el
producto de trabajo es en coches por
ahora que llega hasta 15 entonces déjame
ponerle como por acá el 15 digamos que
por acá está y más o menos por ahí está
el 10 y que por acá esté el 5 va y aquí
tenemos la cantidad de lavadores de lava
autos o de labor vaya de elaborar de
lava autos por hora y puede ir desde 1
hasta 5 lo voy a poner aquí 1 y luego
aquí un poco más a la izquierda para que
quepan
2 3 4 5 6 1 2 3 4 5 entonces pasando
esta información acá para tenerla un
poco más visual nos dice que 0
trabajadores pueden lavar 0 autos un
trabajador puede lavar 5 autos sería
este punto de por acá 2 trabajadores
pueden lavar 9 autos tantito abajo de 10
más o menos por ahí
luego tenemos tres trabajadores
lavándose autos tantito arriba de 10
luego 4 trabajadores 14 autos y
finalmente 5 trabajadores 5 trabajadores
pueden lavar 15 autos entonces tenemos
un punto como por acá muy bien entonces
ahí tenemos algunos ciertos puntos que
nos dicen con cuántos trabajadores
podemos lavar cuántos autos y podemos
más o menos este pues pues hacer está
estos puntos una una curva uniéndolos o
uniéndolos ya sea con rectas o con una o
con una curva que se ajuste bien pero
aquí está voy a pensar que los uno con
rectas más o menos así luego bajó a cada
nuevo valor para acá y luego va para acá
muy bien esto ya nos da información
visual de cómo está el producto de
trabajo en términos de los trabajadores
que tenemos de labor que tenemos pero
ahora queremos decidir económicamente
cuántos trabajadores debemos contratar y
para esto tenemos que pensar
en cada trabajador adicional qué
beneficios nos trae y bueno después
vamos a pensar en cuánto le pagamos y
así pero una cosa muy importante en
términos económicos es el beneficio
marginal que podemos obtener con cada
trabajador que agregamos a nuestro
lavado de autos entonces ahora lo que
voy a considerar a considerar es el
producto marginal del trabajo ya no el
producto de trabajo sino el producto
marginal del trabajo es decir vamos a
pensar pasando de 0 a un trabajador es
cuántos coches más pude lavar luego de
12 de 2 a 3 y así sucesivamente entonces
de 0 a un trabajador es
y aumente el lavado de autos en 5 verdad
antes no lavaba nada y ahora tengo 5 de
1 a 2 pase de 59 que son 4 autos
como aquí 4 de 9 a 12 ahora son 33 luego
de 12 a 14 son 2 y finalmente de 14 a 15
es 1
una vez más vamos a graficar esto para
tener la información visual para
entenderlo un poco mejor
aquí voy a poner voy a poner los ejes de
este mismo color verde
estoy usando ahí tenemos los ejes
tenemos por aquí flechitas aquí una vez
más tenemos lavado todos pueden ser 1 2
3 4 5 son personas que contratamos por
ahora luego aquí poder luego aquí
tenemos que poner esto verdad que va del
1 al 5 le voy a poner 1 2 3 4 5 y como
le estamos haciendo para calcular pues
este 5 vino de restar 5 con este 0 este
4 339 con 5 y además como es como por
trabajador por ahora entonces esto nos
dice cuántos coches adicionales estamos
obteniendo por trabajador por ahora
entonces acá es producto marginal del
trabajo producto marginal de trabajo que
puede ser uno dos tres cuatro o cinco y
las unidades están están algo curiosas
verdad pero son como como coches
adicionales por trabajador por hora
bueno entonces déjame poner los puntos y
ahora cuando pasamos de 0 a 1 y observa
aquí este 5 lo puse entre los dos
renglones indicando que estoy pasando de
0 a 1 este 4 también lo puse entre los
dos renglones de manera similar aquí voy
a poner aquí entre 0 y 1 que estoy
obteniendo 5 coches adicionales luego
vamos a pasar de 1 a 2 aquí voy a poner
4 4 coches aquí tocaría 3
luego tocaría y 22 coches adicionales
observa como siempre los estoy poniendo
a la mitad y finalmente voy a poner aquí
un coche adicional muy bien entonces ahí
tenemos esos 5 puntos en términos del
producto marginal de trabajo que nos
dicen pues lo que nos puedan una forma
de pensar esto es que nos dicen la
pendiente promedio entre estos dos
puntos y bueno digo la pendiente
promedio porque también podríamos tener
una cantidad intermedia de trabajadores
después platicamos acerca de eso pero es
básicamente la pendiente que tiene esta
recta de acá o dicho en términos de pues
de términos económicos es que tanto
beneficio adicional estamos obteniendo
por el entre el 0 y un trabajador entre
el primero y segundo entre el segundo y
tercero y así una vez más que podemos
unir ésta
esta gráfica de acá unimos este punto
con este luego este con este y si te das
cuenta va quedando como una línea recta
y en efecto es una línea recta como le
podemos hacer para verificar pues mirad
si avanzamos si avanzamos en uno hacia
la derecha es decir si aumentamos un
trabajador entonces ésta disminuye en
uno el vuelvo a poner que éste se labor
que es el producto marginal del trabajo
éste disminuye en uno para entonces
siempre estamos avanzando en uno y
disminuyendo disminuyendo el mundo sale
ok entonces esto nos dice que siempre
esta curva tiene la misma pendiente
entonces bueno es una recta pero a su
vez estos puntos representan la
pendiente de esta otra curva de acá muy
bien bueno lo que ya tenemos todo en
términos de producto marginal del
trabajo es decir este este trabajo y qué
beneficio adicional nos está dando
por cada trabajador adicional pero esto
está en términos de coches y de en
términos de coches lavados a lo mejor
nosotros queremos todo en términos pero
de dinero entonces ahora deja de ponerle
por aquí el ingreso por el producto
marginal el ingreso del producto
marginal es decir ahora si en términos
monetarios en términos de pesos cuánto
nos está dando cada trabajador adicional
entonces otra vez voy a poner las cosas
como en este renglón sí y el cálculo es
más o menos sencillo como como el precio
de cada lavada de auto es de 50 sin
importar cuántas adicionales tenemos
entonces aquí nada más tenemos que
multiplicar por 50 entonces estos
trabajadores que son web perdón de estos
coches lavados que son cinco coches
adicionales nos dan 250 pesos
adicionales 250 luego aquí tendría que
ser 200 abajo es 150 luego pasamos a 100
a 100 y finalmente a 50 lo único que
hice es multiplicar por 5 cada uno de
estos y la cantidad de lavadas
adicionales por el precio de cada lavada
esa es la cantidad de dinero adicional
el ingreso del producto marginal que
estamos obteniendo cada vez que pasamos
a tener más y más lavador es muy bien
finalmente vamos a graficar esto de acá
y la gráfica es muy similar a esta de
hecho va a ser igual y está nada más hay
que tener bueno hay que tener en mente
dejar mejor m hacia abajo hay que tener
en mente este que vamos a cambiar este
eje de acá porque ahora ya no va a estar
de 1 a 5 sino de 50 250 pero con es
realmente es muy sencillo graficar esto
no nos ponemos por aquí un eje por acá
el otro eje que ahora déjame pintar aquí
las flechitas ahora lo que vamos a
graficar es el ingreso del producto
marginal le pongo un ingreso del
producto marginal ahora sería en pesos
adicionales por trabajador por hora
adicional entonces bueno y las unidades
serían eso
déjame ponerle aquí que va hasta hasta
hasta 250 entonces hay son 50 aquí son
luego aquí es 150 200 y finalmente 250 y
aquí en l
otra vez tenemos de 1 a 5 2 3 4 5 son
trabajadores por hora
entonces la gráfica se ve muy parecida a
ésta de acá tenemos el punto de 0 a 1
tenemos 250 de 0 a 1 son 250
ok hasta ese punto está entre estos dos
valores luego de 1 a 2 tenemos 200
de 2 a 3 tenemos 150 de 3 a 4 de 3 a 4
tenemos 100
y de 4 a 5 tenemos 50 una vez más es una
recta una forma de pensarlo y es con
esto de las pendientes pero otra forma
de pensar es que básicamente está de acá
le estamos multiplicando por 50 entonces
todos los valores se multiplican por 50
y todo sigue quedando en una recta muy
bien déjame acabar de completar esta
lista línea claro ahorita voy a
completarla pero para justificar que se
puede completar podemos pensar en medios
trabajadores y así ya podemos pensar en
trabajadores que contratamos nada más
por mediodía entonces si tenemos todo un
intervalo de trabajadores por acá
digamos continuo esto se va moviendo
continuamente bueno el producto de
trabajo se mueve continuamente esto
también continuamente y entonces es así
que las líneas completas bueno esto de
acá en realidad es una curva de demanda
curva de demanda
es una curva de demanda justamente para
los trabajadores en esta buena en este
mercado los trabajadores que lavan
coches van entonces esto podemos
pensarlo como una curva de demanda o
como una curva de beneficio marginal ok
entonces estos puntos cada uno de estos
puntos nos dice pues cuál es el
beneficio adicional que estamos
obteniendo y los podemos pensar ya sea
como el beneficio promedio que nos dan
estos trabajadores de acá o ahorita como
es discreto como el beneficio adicional
que nos da este trabajador o sea de
pasar de cero a un trabajadores luego de
1 a 2 de 2 a 3 y así sucesivamente bueno
esta es una curva de demanda nada más
para nuestra nuestra empresa de lavado
de autos verdad nada más una última idea
que te quiero decir
es que podemos tomar estas curvas de
demanda variada para varias empresas
para todos
todos los lavados de auto de la ciudad
las podemos sumar y eso nos va a dar la
curva de demanda pero para todo el
mercado de lavadores de autos